you're the type of patient that many of
us doctors are terrified of because you
you've been through all this so you have
all this collected trauma you have a
complex medical condition that we don't
fully understand but we think we do but
we want to feel like we do so we reduce
it to receptors and pills and so on but
we're not seeing the full
biopsychosocial thing because it's
complicated and we don't get paid for
that we don't have the time for that and
for that reason you're a challenge to us
that hurts us morally because we want to
help you and we know we can't
welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
episode 85. on this episode I am joined
by Z dog Dr Zubin de Mania I wanted to
talk to Dr Z because I have a lot of
alternative health professionals on my
podcast and you guys know how I feel
about most mainstream medical doctors
however I'm also aware that because of
my experience I am very biased I think
Dr Z Falls right in the middle of my
more alternative View and the mainstream
medical view the alt middle
we had a fantastic conversation I
actually had a lot of fun with this guy
we spoke about the virus what a proper
response for nursing homes could have
looked like different vaccines across
the world mRNA vaccines vaccine
passports touched on my health struggles
the impacts of various diets the
importance of skepticism and more
zdog MD is an American physician
assistant professor comedian internet
personality and musician if you enjoy
this content please hit subscribe
this episode is brought to you by true
local
trulocal.ca use code MP for free Stakes
who doesn't love free steaks you may
have heard me talk about this company
multiple times for a while because they
basically sponsor every Health episode
because they're great but I was using
them even before they sponsored my
podcast with true local you choose what
goes in your box and they send it to you
they have any meat you could possibly
want some organs the meat is super high
quality what true local does is they
connect with local farmers so you get to
buy farmed meat sustainable nutritious
tastes great not the typical meat you'd
find at your local grocery chain that
comes out of giant slaughterhouses
an added benefit is you get an amazing
product while at the same time
supporting local farmers if you want to
get healthy incorporating more meat into
your diet is literally the easiest way
to do it go to
trulocal.ca and use code MP for free
steaks I hope you enjoy this
conversation
[Music]
Zubin welcome to my podcast uh can we
start off by you giving anyone who's
listening who doesn't know you a bit of
a background about who you are and what
it is you do
absolutely and thanks for having me on
by the way uh it's a real thrill um so
I'm I'm uh
I'm a kid born from immigrant parents
from India but they're like this ancient
Persian ancestry they're both doctors so
I had no choice I ended up becoming a
doctor went to UCSF medical school and
then uh Stanford for my residency
practiced uh inpatient Hospital medicine
for 10 years really uh I'm gonna use the
very stigmatizing term burnout suffered
that uh woke up started putting videos
on YouTube under an alter ego called Z
dog MD that became a thing uh moved to
Las Vegas worked with the CEO of Zappos
uh built a clinic that utilizes
something we call Health 3.0 and now I
have an internet show called The Z dog
MD show that we talk about anything that
we can from a rationalist alt middle
perspective so that's more or less my
story
okay alt middle I like it uh I want to
talk about well some of the things I
want to talk about we should just get
out of the way I want to talk about
covid because that is what everybody is
talking about right now and I just came
from Toronto which uh is under a new
lockdown even though the old lockdown
didn't end and currently there's a
stay-at-home mandate and you're not
supposed to see family and I've heard
rumors of stopping travel in between
cities within the province
so Ontario has been hit really really
hard with restrictions and um I had
covid last July and I've been
I I guess you'd call me I've been an
outspoken critic against
um government mandated restrictions
they've put in
um so I'd probably fall more on
what the news would call the right
perspective on covid but I wanted to get
you on uh to get your opinion on a whole
bunch of things so
first off can we start with how
dangerous do you believe covet is
well you know I'll say this first of all
Michaela by questioning government
mandates you are basically murdering
Grandma so you're a horrible person and
I'm going to judge you like everybody on
Twitter will judge you uh okay just get
that out of the way uh so as you can
tell I'm a little biased probably in
your direction
so okay okay so your question was how
dangerous do I think covet is or what
yeah
um
this is such a nuanced question and yet
we have to kind of you know we have to
present it as I also I also was like is
it how dangerous is it period just like
no Direction there but uh go ahead no
but I love it because that's that's the
question that the public wants to know
right so why can't we answer that
properly and and I this is how I
conceive of this it that that question
has an answer for you it does not have
an answer for a population it doesn't
have an answer for everybody it has an
answer for you and it depends on how old
you are what your other diseases are How
likely you are to contract covid how
much on the front lines you are
um and your own risk tolerance uh so how
much are you willing to take risks like
when you get in a car you're a young
person you know in your 20s
a 24 year old and younger is 36 times
more likely to die of a car accident
than they are of covid so for them covet
is much less dangerous than for a 65 and
older who they're twice as likely to die
of covid than of a car accident but what
we've done as a as a policy is we've not
acknowledged that so we do all the
backwards things we shut our schools
down we shut down everything we stop
travel between cities I mean this what
you're saying they're doing in Canada is
crazy and this is nuts because
yeah yeah but do you think it's actually
happening
I read an article suggesting it was so I
would assume yes but we'll see in the
next couple weeks I mean if they prevent
Getty Lee and Alex liveson from leaving
Toronto uh to to tour uh the members of
Rush then I will become violent um
that I'd be okay with that as long as
I'm out of Toronto
[Laughter]
so um you know this this idea of then
having a a different answer for is it
dangerous for different subsets of
people means you have to have a
different response for different subsets
of people so what we've done is we've
closed schools
dumb because you're looking if you're a
hammer everything's a nail right so if
you're a person who's worried about
covid specifically then you're going to
shut down schools thinking well we might
drop a little bit of the transmission
even though kids don't transmit it so
aggressively the new variants may be a
little bit more but not that much and
what we don't look at the downside of
shutting schools which is a regressive
tax on poor people like it you you and I
like we're communicating by Zoom right
now we're in the zoomocracy we're the
laptop barati right we can survive and
thrive
in this world but the kid whose mom is
an essential worker cannot they need
school they need school for structure
they need it for meals they need it for
Education they need it for a path out so
that they can actually Express their
true authentic self in the world and
what the
laptoparati have done the public health
apparatus and our governments and and a
lot of people are complicit in this that
they said you know what yeah we can go
ahead and shut down because I can still
make a damn good living in fact I might
do better in this world when I don't
have to commute and see Bob in the
office and have him cough on me and and
and that's why I think this question of
like is kova dangerous the answer is yes
in the sense that it's dangerous to what
we've done to ourselves as a society we
haven't
targeted our
um our restrictions in a way that's
going to protect vulnerable people we've
harmed those vulnerable people and we
still have huge numbers of infections
and deaths so we suck at this honestly
okay
okay I agree with that bit of a rant
no no that was good I've definitely
ranted about this before I thought that
the people who got hit are the people
who
are losing their jobs not making very
much money not the people who are like
yeah okay I'll take a couple months a
year stay at home like I have an office
job that'll pay me or I'm on Zoom you
know it's not then those are the people
who are in charge of saying yeah this is
what we'll do for everyone because
they're so removed from the people who
have to go out and work all day it's
like it's like Dr Evil is making the
rules for everyone you know and this guy
is not a normal guy like he's a bald
dude with a mini me who sits there going
you know I have summers in Rangoon you
know in Spring we made meat helmets uh
everybody needs to shut down so I can
sit here and pet my cat and still make a
lot of money the wealth and Equity has
actually gotten worse during
covet now this is what kills me so when
you think of this from an ALT middle
perspective and ALT middle is something
that we came up with that is simply says
you say yes and to all ideas you assume
good intent and then you start to pick
them apart and critically think for
yourself so you're not an idea your dad
has said this never be an ideological
purist I forget the term he uses he
calls it um
there was a term he used in other words
if you say you're a liberal don't just
check all the boxes like well then that
means I don't want uh I'm pro-choice and
I'm this and that no no you can be a
complex thing for yourself human being
that just thinks critically on each
issues based on your own moral palette
so this idea of alt middle is don't have
that ideological Purity think be
open-minded be critical be integral in
your thinking so you sort of integrate
all these perspectives and don't assume
the world is divided into good and bad
people it's actually much more nuanced
than that so the um
the kind of alt middle you know
perspective on this is well liberals
ought to be outraged at how we've hurt
the poor like we have destroyed the poor
it is a disease of now poor minorities
they are the ones who die and we sit at
home tisking well you need to wear then
two masks
maybe it's your fault that you got
covered
[ __ ] off like can I say that on the show
is that okay yes
are you kidding me that's the most
patronizing condescending classist
elitist [ __ ] and the the left ought
to understand that that's what you're
supposed to be against and then the
right says well you're not telling me
what to do no matter what and it's like
well but sometimes we need to think a
little more as a community and go well
how can we protect our nursing home
people that means that we all have to do
a little part like if you go into a
supermarket you should probably wear a
mask because there's old people shopping
there all right fine we can have these
compromises but we see the world in
black and white and I think that's been
very damaging and it doesn't help that
the media fans those flames
okay
um one comment I really like how you
transition from uh Dr Evil to normal
person speaking voice so easily like you
must have done that a lot that was my
takeaway there which is no formal
training just you know the details of my
life are quite inconsequential
what do you think the proper response
would have been for nursing homes like
should they have
it's been really like it's been really
awful with people separated from their
loved ones and
um saying that that well that's for your
own safety but not giving people the
option in Ontario uh there was at least
one nursing home that actually locked
and removed doorknobs from patients with
covid who were in the nursing home to
stop them from leaving I don't know if
they had Alzheimer's or what their
reasoning was because there couldn't be
any but removed doorknobs and nobody
found out about it because people
couldn't go in to see their loved ones
this is like one of those Saw horror
movies you know like you're stuck in a
nursing home and they take the doorknobs
out and you have a little bit of
dementia and you're disoriented and
you're on 13 psychotropic medications
because the doctors don't know what to
do with you and you're bouncing off the
walls and then they take your one source
of orientation away and listen you can
you can you can make a distinction
between the early pandemic when we
didn't have enough PPE when our staff
were dying when they were like keep
visitors out of here and so on okay
that's one thing we didn't know what was
happening everybody was terrified we
know better now and what we're doing is
perpetuating a human rights violation
this is a human rights violation telling
people they can't see their loved ones
unless they're on hospice and that by
the way forces people to go on hospice I
mean it is coercion it's inhuman
Healthcare professionals feel it we feel
it as a kind of moral conflict a kind of
injury because we're seeing these people
die alone we're holding up the phone so
that they can Skype I mean this is
absurd it's we're gonna look back at
this and there's going to be
documentaries made like Schindler's List
style where we go go oh my God what did
we do to these poor people there are
Fates worse than death their Fates worse
than death and we've listed them on
people so yes I'm with you I think the
answer for the nursing home thing in my
mind would have been this
uh yes focus on getting them PPE and and
mass and protection uh and the second
thing is give paid leave for any of
their staff that get sick because what
people don't realize is nursing home
staff a lot of them are lower level pay
grade people they're the same essential
workers that we talk about getting
screwed in all this they can't miss a
day of work if they have a cough or they
feel a little fever they're going to
come in because they can't get paid
potentially pay them to stay home then
and then you you can help people a lot
they are understaffed they they
themselves suffer it's a horrible
situation and then and you know what's
happening now Michaela is I'm getting
messages from nursing home doctors who
are telling me you got to talk about
this
now that the staff and the patients are
all vaccinated
they are still instituting these
ridiculous rules even though the data
shows that with vaccination you're
pretty much done right nobody will say
that in public health because like well
you know but if one person dies who's
vaccinated that's that's safety creep no
the vaccines are the answer that's why
like you know this idea of shutting down
cities and doing lockdowns shut the hell
up and vaccinate people who want to be
vaccinated don't coerce it who want to
be vaccinated and will be done with this
that's just it
uh so I'm in Dubai right now and
it it's crazy I've never been here
before uh it's
it's crazy out here but vaccine wise
um you can go anywhere if you live here
I believe it's free most people have
been vaccinated they're thrilled about
it and you can go into like doctor's
offices and things and just get the
vaccine it doesn't matter who you are
and if you do blood tests to monitor I
just talked to somebody about this you
do blood tests to monitor your antibody
level and then you can get boosters
until your antibody level stabilizes and
it's something that's just implemented
in Abu Dhabi I think it's something like
80 80 something percent of them are
vaccinated and in Canada like nobody
under the age of 55 at the moment can
get it this one guy I talked to got his
first vaccination last August I was like
we didn't even know a vaccine existed
then like how is it that there are areas
of the world that are so far ahead of
North America when we grow up learning
at least I grew up learning like this is
the best place on Earth we have the best
medical system in the entire world which
is a total lie alive I'm traveling
around that's a lot yeah oh yeah that
but what what what's going on
yeah so I think the rest of the world
has a different tolerance for risk so
they say you know what yeah the thing's
good enough let's go sign them back okay
Russian vaccine in America we're so
litigation averse we're so afraid of
being sued and Canada is probably very
similar maybe to a different degree
um we in America particularly we have a
very fragmented Health Care system so
you can't even coordinate distribution
of vaccine which was a problem early on
it's getting better but it was
definitely a problem early on and I
understand like when you're vaccinating
healthy people the the danger of causing
harm is actually big because you you
vaccinated a thousand healthy people
that are low risk for covid and three of
them die those three never would have
died of covid we're now creating a
problem so you have to be cautious but
not insane but the interesting thing so
you look at like for example in Canada
now we have the AstraZeneca vaccine now
it just I've done a few shows on
AstraZeneca now the the two mRNA
vaccines
um uh Pfizer and moderna I've never seen
data that looks this good like it's
ridiculous they're so safe and effective
you look at uh Johnson and Johnson's
single dose vaccine looks really good
right maybe a little less effective but
even that is kind of plus or minus
because
it's complex but AstraZeneca
the difficulty here is and and this is
why science actually works so even if
you have a certain risk tolerance you
have to look at it and go oh what's
going on here with AstraZeneca millions
of people vaccinated and they start to
catch a few very rare cases of
deep Venous Thrombosis so blood clots in
unusual places the cavernous sinus of
the brain the splanchnic vessels of the
gut oh yeah these things hardly ever
happen and what they're finding is
they're happening in younger women and
we don't know if they're on birth
control which increases your risk of
clotting but they're happening in people
like you and the the question then is in
what in what incidents are they
happening very tiny so you could still
make a a case if you're looking at risk
and go yeah but from a risk benefit
standpoint if AstraZeneca was the only
vaccine we had well you could you should
probably still get it because your risk
of covet is higher in most people but if
you're a woman on oral contraceptives
maybe not so you can start to stratify
but the great thing about the covet
situation is we've thrown so many
resources at vaccines that we could
actually say you know what
um we have other choices for young women
and for p people that societies that can
afford the more expensive vaccines and
so on so we can then start to parse out
risk there's no one-size-fits all and I
think that's very important now this
kind question that you brought up about
antibodies and testing and then
reboosting I don't know that there's a
lot of science behind that it's a
strategy that hasn't been studied very
well but hey if they want to do it
yeah yeah it's just because we don't and
I'll tell you why
um we don't fully understand that
the antibody levels directly correlate
to immunity because the immunity is
multifocal there's a T cell mediated
immunity that doesn't have to do with
antibodies the we've measured anybody's
declining in people but what we don't
measure is their B cell clonal response
that when you get reinfected the B cells
which are the memory part they just
start spitting out antibody again the
Clone Army gets reactivated so I think
it's more complex than simply measuring
titers but time will tell and research
will bear it out
okay so in that case how do you feel
about them suggesting that people who've
already had covid
um
get the vaccine isn't the point of
catching something like measles that you
don't have to get vaccinated again like
right what's going on here this is a
great question so
um measly a good example
measles vaccine and measles and RNA
virus just like coronavirus
um measles vaccine is 96 or higher
effective in people who've had both
shots and there is uh you know they're
the six months apart MMR vaccination
it's remarkable and it's lifelong for
most people and it's what they call
sterilizing immunity meaning once you're
immune that [ __ ] can't can't infect you
at all
um it'd be very hard very very hard so
that that's one extreme another extreme
is something like influenza vaccine
where the virus mutates yeah every year
and these surface antigens that we're
targeting with the vaccine change every
year and we have to hope we predict it
right and so on and that's why influenza
vaccine is you know 50 60 effective in
some years sometimes lower because we
get the match wrong so that's the Other
Extreme now where coronavirus sits
is in an unknown area because we've
never made a vaccine against coronavirus
we know coronavirus mutates we have
these variants they're less
um they're less neutralized by the
antibodies we measure with current
vaccines but that doesn't tell us
whether the vaccines actually are
effective against them what tells us is
real world data which is showing us that
they are quite effective against what we
care about which is severe disease and
death so
the debate then is how long will it last
do we need a booster if will the
variants require new boosters and the
answer is maybe we don't know and how
long will they last well we know they
last at least six months in the terms of
the Pfizer vaccine because that's how
far they've been measured out with very
robust immunity people my friend Paul
offit who's one of the experts on this
thinks that the immunity is at least a
year probably longer and that
um if we need a booster it's because a
new variants have emerged that will
require an update but that's not a big
deal and it probably won't take a two
shot booster it'll probably be one the
other question you asked was the should
people who've had covid get vaccinated
was that the question
yeah yeah
um this is such a good and nuanced and
complicated question because anyone who
says they have the answer to this is
operating from a data set that's
incomplete and they're just making [ __ ]
up out of their ass so this is what I
think about this I think that
in a perfect world with perfect
resources
everyone who's had coveted would get
vaccinated and this is why
it appears particularly with the MRNA
vaccines that the and again this this
contradicts something I said earlier
which is that the antibody response
itself is maybe not the best measure of
how robust the immunity is but the
correlates of immunity are stronger in
people who've had both doses of the MRNA
vaccines than they are in naturally
infected people
there's other early data that kind of
says people who've been naturally
infected if they've been vaccinated tend
to resist reinfection with variants
maybe more so there's stuff that still
is being studied that would say okay
maybe there's a good reason to go ahead
and get that vaccine now the question is
do you get one or both doses if you're
doing mRNA and is one enough and we just
we there's some data that says maybe it
is but we don't have enough data to be
able to answer it conclusively so again
it gets back to you what is your risk
sort of determination if you understand
okay you're you know Michaela maybe
where you're like 28 something
um young person younger even younger I
like that 29 I'm 29. damn it you know
yeah now I'm almost 30. it hurts me too
more I mean well you look about 16 so
you have that going for you but see this
is the thing I've always it's the zoom
blur
people are people are always like what
kind of beauty filter are you using
Zubin because you're like you know
turning 48 this month and I'm like it's
called lighting and a really nice camera
with a with a soft lens because if you
see me in person I look like the Crypt
Keeper so oh I need a soft lens yeah you
need to know anyway
we'll we'll definitely talk uh camera
Tech because uh it's okay yes please but
yours looks great so
oh what were we talking about I derailed
myself on this oh risk risk for the
personal so if you're gonna get the
actual coveted vaccine you have to look
at yourself and go well okay I'm a young
person I had covid it was pretty mild I
didn't I don't know about your case I'm
just projecting it was a mild thing I
didn't die
um I didn't become a long hauler or
whatever that is and nothing else
happened so do I need to get vaccinated
now probably not well maybe I live with
an old person that's at high risk and
they've been vaccinated so maybe now
they're at lower risk so what should I
do so it's it's a tough calculation but
everyone has to make it for themselves I
think
avoiding the question I like it okay
um
no that's fair though that's a fair
response can we quickly cover I have two
questions can you describe what an mRNA
vaccine is and do we have any studies of
other mRNA vaccines
excellent question so the technology has
been around in some form been studied
for at least a decade or two and the
idea is that messenger RNA is this very
you know unique naturally made component
of cellular metabolism where you have
your DNA in your in the nucleus of the
cell it encodes all your genetic
information what's amazing is every
single cell of your body has the entire
genome that could basically create a
whole human and it gets philosophical
and you go wow every cell of us is a
whole and a part of a whole in and of
itself and that that's
spiritually quite interesting so there's
that
the DNA is transcribed into mRNA by an
apparatus that does this and it spits
out a little copy like a little
transcript that's a slightly different
compound that then leaves the nucleus
goes to the cytoplasm of the cell where
it goes through a Machinery with
ribosomes and so on where that messenger
RNA is like an email from the nucleus
it tells the cellular Machinery this is
the protein you need to make and when
that protein is made from the MRNA it
undergoes this complex folding process
and packaging in the you know
endoplasmic reticulum and all the Golgi
apparatus and all that stuff you learned
in high school biology and then promptly
forgot
um that stuff then is how we make
proteins so the way the MRNA vaccines
work is we hijacked this aspect of
normal cellular function we said okay
we want the body to see the spike
protein the business end of this virus
and recognize it because that's the end
that binds to ace2 receptors and allows
the virus to enter our cells if we can
surround that area with antibodies
that's one way to knock the virus out to
neutralize it that's why they use the
term neutralizing antibodies antibodies
are simply proteins
that recognize the shape of what they're
attacking and Surround it and bind to it
in different spots so if the spike
protein has these different locations
neutralizing antibodies recognize and
binds stick to it like a lock and a key
and then that neutralizes the virus
either by preventing it from binding to
cells or by flagging it so when when you
have these antibodies there are other
cells helper T cells killer killer cells
that then recognize that this thing's
been flagged and actually destroy the
cell that is infected by it so because
the cells that have that are infected by
coronavirus they display this Spike
protein on its surface kind of like hey
guys look at this is this right am I
supposed to be making this and the
helper T cells go oh hell no and they
they they can trigger a Cascade that
causes death of that cell so it's like
hey suicide yourself for the good of the
of the of the rest all right so what you
want to do then is prime the immune
system because in order to spin up this
response it takes time and that's why
you get sick the virus is replicating
you feel like [ __ ] because your immune
system is starting to generate cytokines
and interferons and things like that
that make you feel all the symptoms that
people complain about both with
coronavirus and with the vaccine
that helps the immune system function
fever actually helps the immune system
function that's why I tell people don't
treat your fever if you can avoid it
when you're getting the vaccine even
when you're sick if you can avoid it
unless it's just killing you or it's
very high and the doctor tells you you
need to so so that being said the way
the MRNA vaccine then teaches your
immune system this in advance so that it
can respond quickly is
we take that email that mRNA and we
create it in a lab and we say okay we
know the sequence of the
um mRNA that is going to tell the cell
how to make the spike protein let's just
put it in a little package because and
this is important mRNA is so transient
it's so ephemeral it's so easily broken
down that once it's in the cytoplasm
it's gone in in no time at all once it
makes the protein it gets broken down if
you inject it into an arm by itself it
just goes it just crumbles because it's
not designed to survive outside of cells
so you wrap it in a little fat bubble
they call it the lipid nanoparticle
because they want to get nerdy about it
but really it's just a little bubble of
oil that they've designed that allows it
then to merge with the bubble of oil
that is our cell because our cell
membrane is basically like a little oily
bubble that keeps the inside and the
outside separate so once it merges the
the RNA enters that cell and it does the
same thing that mRNA always does it gets
transcribed into protein the body makes
the spike protein it shows it on the
surface all our immune system goes hey
what's that and starts finding clonal b
cells to go no that's not okay and Spins
up a response that's why
eight hours after the second dose or so
when I got moderna I felt the worst I
felt in decades like and I've been sick
here and there right I'm a doctor I get
sick from patients and stuff I was
knocked on my ass with fevers muscle
aches chills rigors headache brain fog
everything and what's fascinating
Michaela is that
this was the first time I could go
because I've had every vaccine in the
book this is the first time I could go
oh [ __ ] like this is what the immune
response feels like minus the infection
itself and so every time I've had a flu
or a cold and I feel like crap 95 of
those symptoms are your own immune
system going ape [ __ ] and the other five
percent are the viral replication the
cough the phlegm the you know the
constant hacking and I didn't have any
of that because there's no virus in this
vaccine it's just the spike protein so
it doesn't do all that stuff so it's
really quite fascinating so then it
gives your body a master's tutorial in
how to make this uh protein the next
time when the virus comes it's like it
has no chance because we spin up the
Clone Army right away and knock it out
of commission
that's kind of what my experience with
covid was like like it was 18 days ah it
wasn't that bad I had a mild fever like
37.6 for a couple days I could feel a
wheeze and I was like uh oh what does
this have but then nothing happened
um and I was off and on like achy for 18
days
um but I didn't have like I wasn't
sneeze it was like I was a little bit
Sneezy but I was a tiny bit Sneezy but
it wasn't that bad my nanny had one day
of an upset stomach my stomach was upset
actually that was one of the big
symptoms as my digestion was upset my
kid got the rash like the covid rash she
got a rash on her hands and her feet my
husband had similar symptoms to me but
it wasn't like
it wasn't the worst I've well I felt
pretty bad in the last 10 years though
so the worst I felt is not a good
comparison uh what are the other are
there other mRNA vaccines that we would
be
uh familiar with
not really no these are sort of freaking
people out commercial ones right now you
know I think for Ebola
um I'm forgetting the exact mechanism of
That vaccine but again that's not a
vaccine that everybody gets right that's
one of those like esoteric vaccines and
um so and so it freaks people out yes
and this is how I think about that
because listen I was super skeptical
dude because I thought this whole thing
was politicized from the beginning like
is the vaccine going to be politicized
too it has been yeah and it has been so
but what's interesting is it it's been
politicized in both ways so when Trump
was pushing the vaccines everyone was
like oh my God it's going to be
trumpified and it's going to come out
too early and they're going to push it
and everybody all the left was scared
and I was like I'm not getting no
vaccine now that you know Biden's
spinning up vaccines the right is like
hell no I'm not taking this Biden
vaccine and it's like well guys like
let's just look at the actual data here
and and understand that my conclusion
being skeptical so I've made multiple
videos over the course of the pandemic
make and you can see I I'm just like
well okay if this thing happens in less
than a year I'm going to be shocked and
then we see in less than a year that the
trial data comes out and I'm like now
wait a minute so then I I call up Paul
offit the expert who sits on the FDA
advisory committee comes on my show and
we talk about it and he's like they did
it I mean they they actually got enough
trial participants and this so this is
why it was possible to happen so fast
and why we can reassure people that this
is not insane because boy it feels wrong
doesn't it like intuition says time
period yeah yeah and I know people
aren't having trouble having kids in a
year did that happen with Gardasil like
people had some issues there after a
while so that that so that yeah that's
what we're talking about yeah yeah the
answer is no but the answer is there is
a public fear contagion with Gardasil
that has spread a lot of misinformation
about Gardasil and um and it's
interesting how it happens because it's
the same thing especially for a vaccine
that has some stigma associated with oh
are we going to be encouraging sexual
intercourse by giving an HPV vaccine and
so on and we're giving it to our young
girls first and there's a lot of
societal stigma around young girl so it
just became a real thing
um but the MRNA vaccine is interesting
we have Decades of research that builds
you to this point people had worked on
it but it was never commercially
um done and the reason is in order to do
a vaccine trial successfully you have to
enroll tens of thousands of people you
have to random and double-blind and
Placebo control it you have to have a
prevalence of the disease that's enough
that you're going to actually show a
difference between the placebo group and
this group so that normally takes years
because the prevalence of disease is so
low that to show an effect you got to
follow patients for years and it takes
forever to recruit patients because
people don't really want to be part of a
vaccine trial typically it's like ah why
would I want to be part of a you know
respiratory syncytial virus trial it's
like I don't care about that and then
comes along covid everyone's [ __ ]
their pants everyone wants to be a part
of the trial instantly they enroll forty
thousand people you know per trial it's
a piece of cake to enroll people so now
you have the people now do you have the
prevalence of the disease well [ __ ] we
do the disease all over the place
everybody's getting it so we can
actually get numbers quickly uh and so
you end up doing the business end of the
trial which is the phase three trial in
humans that looks at both safety and
efficacy that's really what you want you
end up doing it in three three four
months because you can and all the
government read tape says okay we're
going to take the Financial Risk away
because we're going to buy the vaccine
whether it works or not so the Pharma
companies who are [ __ ] are like well
then fine let's do this because they're
scared about losing money right so they
take that off the table and on top of
that this is the first vaccine where
everybody's skin is in the game because
they're like well I have a date with
this vaccine like all the doctors are
like well I'm going to be getting this
vaccine so it better [ __ ] be safe and
effective so they're looking at the data
and they're skeptical and so the people
who care most about this are all of us
for once it's not like you know any
other vaccine almost right and so for
that reason uh when you look at the data
then you go okay this is compelling now
look at the if you worry that the system
fails like maybe we're wrong about this
look at AstraZeneca
this is a situation where the primary
the primary trial data did not show rare
rare rare events of blood clotting World
data did they're still super rare but
when you when you have a trial of 25
million people you pick up very rare
things so you do catch them people do
take it seriously they do respond they
do investigate they do pause campaigns
for better Force they can still make a
case and say risk and benefit says you
should still get the vaccine but then
people can make a decision based on
what's been known about the vaccine and
so that gets to the point if you don't
coerce these vaccines you let you
educate people and you let them make
decisions right
okay so that that's what I was going to
actually one comment first uh do you
know if Khan Academy that's how so I I
took sciences and and calculus just
murdered me and like that YouTube
channel got me through it and your
explanation of how a vaccine works like
brought me back to cell biology but it
was very well done visually like I could
imagine it so
that was very entertaining I could see
why you're popular that as Nick Cage
would say that's High Praise like that's
really kind of you so the con con is a
legendary thing my kids use Khan Academy
and and teaching is one of trying to
teach without stuff in other words
without the visual props means you have
to paint a picture in your own head and
then communicate it it's it's a
challenge but it's also a flow State
authentic Joy if you can get in the
pocket with that and sometimes I do and
sometimes I don't and when I don't I
hear about it from fans they're like
yeah could we have slides and then other
times they're like I get it yeah yeah
yeah okay
um okay so then we were talking about
you shouldn't coerce people so how do
you feel about this a vaccine passport
that steam I don't know a lot about it I
do know that Texas said no I don't know
what Florida said but I like I think New
York and some other places are seriously
considering this
um how do you feel about that yeah this
is another great topic to look at from
an ALT middle perspective an integral
perspective and go okay
what's involved what's at play here and
why does our own moral Matrix actually
determine how we're going to respond to
this so a vaccine passport is simply
saying the following it's saying by
showing evidence of you being vaccinated
having previous infection having
antibodies whatever you want to use to
define a green card right like I get a
pass
you can then allow certain restrictions
to evaporate much more rapidly so for
example a restaurant could fill its room
back to back no social distancing with
vaccinated people who have a vaccine
passport
um you could fill a plane with
vaccinated people and maybe turn take
the masks off you could
uh allow travel into countries that have
been otherwise restrictive with a
vaccine passport you could go to
sporting events and fill a stadium with
people who have a vaccine passport okay
well in theory this sounds cool from The
Stance off
protection of people so if you have a
care versus harm moral sensibility that
is is prominent in you you go well that
sounds good Liberty versus oppression
moral palette says wait a minute now you
want me to show you my papers so that I
can do what I ought to be doing anyways
which is being that's me yeah [ __ ] you
everywhere me too
exactly I mean you and I are very
similar we have this Oppositional
Defiant Disorder it's like don't you
don't tell me what to do and I won't
tell you what to do uh but I will tell
you what I think uh but yeah and and so
that that is very strong in a lot of
people and they just immediately like an
immune response reject the idea now
what's interesting is
there are other aspects to this and that
is equity and Justice aspects so say say
you have a more liberal palette of um
fairness versus cheating
and care versus harm you can look at
this and go wait so you're saying that
rich people who can get access to the
vaccines faster older people who get
access to the vaccines faster are now
preferentially able to go and enjoy life
whereas the rest of us who haven't
gotten the vaccine who don't have access
who are say maybe in Canada who haven't
had access yet we can't [ __ ] off right
so already there's an inequity in that
and it it it then further solidifies
this Zoom let's okay now I'm
editorializing but okay so those are the
kind of issues and we have kind of
vaccine passports for certain
international travel like I think some
countries require yellow fever and
different different uh vaccinations but
that that's a yes subtle thing right now
this is what I think
by by talking about vaccine passports
we're distracting ourselves from the
real issue which is just get as many
people vaccinated who are willing to be
vaccinated as you can and the pandemic's
over let's focus on that having a dangle
a vaccine passport is only going to help
rich people and people who have quick
access to vaccines
all you're going to do is double down on
the [ __ ] ups we've already done which is
hurting poor people closing schools
destroying a generation of kids who are
vulnerable and helping people like you
and I who are part of the zumocracy who
can make a ton of uh can make a living
and continue to work sitting at home
while tisking uh uh people for not
wearing five masks
um and then all week but we have a
vaccine passport so I'm on the beach
without a mask now [ __ ] off you know it
really does trigger that kind of
response
okay I'm curious what you think what do
I have
um I don't
I don't like the idea of putting like
anything on anybody or forcing anybody
to do anything even though I know that
that would probably not end up well you
need some guidelines but I'd like to
like like you said get the proper
information out like this fear-mongering
is so nauseating especially in Ontario
it's so bad like our um our Premiere has
full-on said that going against any of
the
any of these covid lockdowns is
political suicide and it was it's like
well people are actually killing
themselves in lockdown like they're
actually dying it's not just their like
they're it's not just political suicide
for some people
um but I'm yeah I'm not I'm I'm not into
I'm not into that but I also have a bit
of a bias which I'm fully aware of
because I was so sick as a kid that I've
spoken with Specialists who've said you
could have this could have been an
adverse reaction to a vaccine we don't
know it's unlikely but it could have
played a role because I had like I had
arthritis at two right like um so I'm
like I already have a bias about putting
anything into my like anything into my
body especially now that I'm healthy so
then I think well if I don't want it
then I shouldn't Force other people
to do this and I have like I have
members my family who've gone to get the
vaccine who've been thrilled about it
they haven't even noticed right in in
Canada and they feel better and they
were at a higher risk and that's totally
fine I'm like I said I'm here in Dubai
and most people are vaccinated and
people are out in the open and things
are better but I don't like the idea of
government mandating where people go
dependent on what they've injected into
their body it freaks me out yeah let's
stick into that a little bit because I
think that's important um your
experience as a child you've been
through hell you know I've watched your
videos and videos with your dad and and
you've been through hell recently you've
been through hell as a child and
juvenile rheumatoid arthritis is not a
[ __ ] joke it is as you I'm preaching
the choir here so we won't get into that
but I'll say this
your search for meaning why did this
happen is the most human of all
reactions and in fact my friend Marty
McCary who's often on the news talking
about covet from a standpoint that we
stand at like you know let's move let's
stop the fear-mongering and let's
actually do the right thing for the most
people without compelling anything and
and um
very smart guy Johns Hopkins Public
Health uh policy guy
he says that he needs a cancer surgeon
and he says the first question about
that he gets when he gives a diagnosis
of cancer is why did this happen to me
what ha what did I do what what happened
and it's the same with autism it's the
same with arthritis with autoimmune
people have to ask the question was it
this was it something that could have
been done and where is my locus of
control could I have done something
differently and these are if you're not
asking these questions you're not a
human being and if you're not concerned
about them you're not a human being and
I think I've fallen into this trap as a
as a sciencey guy of judging you know
anti-vaxxers by like well they're just
crazy you know diluted lunatics and the
truth is now yeah it's easy to do right
because well some are but I mean there
are lunatics everywhere that's true so I
think there's this one percent of really
truly deluded and they get no quarter
from me and I ridicule the mercilessey
but it's folks like folks like yourself
who would have rational concerns and go
well okay could it have been this and
there's not good data that says that it
ever has been in other words your the
actual virus that you're often
vaccinating against
is more likely to cause autoimmune
effects like for example the disease
Guillain-Barre syndrome which is an
autoimmune reaction where you're yeah
your nerves become demyelinated you lose
this it's almost like stripping the
electrical wires of their insulation and
everything just gloms and so you you get
an ascending paralysis it can be fatal
you can stop breathing but often you can
support people through it with
ventilators and so on and you get better
this It's associated with certain
vaccines like influenza vaccine and so
people go oh my God the vaccine is
associated with this thing but then you
look at actually
what happens when you're naturally
infected with influenza you're like
something like 10 times more likely to
get Guillain-Barre from natural
influenza infection so in a way the
vaccine actually reduces the net risk of
getting
Guillain-Barre but it's these are very
hard Concepts to think about and so it's
natural to be frightened the other thing
Michaela is are you are you at all
frightened of needles
no I've been rejected myself since I was
seven right
it's really not yeah it's never been a
thing for you
oh yeah at the beginning it was right
for like 10 years but that says I was
injecting myself that's way worse than
getting a needle yeah it always and for
diabetics same thing so there's some
data that the way we do vaccines in kids
we we take a four to six year old kid we
strap them down two nurses come inject
multiple arms at once and because the
schedule of vaccines actually is really
kind of designed very intentionally that
that's how you generate the best immune
response and so on but what there's some
data emerging I had a doctor named Amy
Baxter on the show talking about this
that in that and your dad might
appreciate this because he talks about
human development and especially kids in
Piaget and these stages of development
in that stage of development between
four and six like when you're younger
than four you don't form very solid
memories you're you're sort of
pre-operational you're not you're not
really so you can inject an infant with
hella vaccines and they don't remember
needle fear or anything like that four
to six the kid is in an OP you know kind
of concrete operational phase where they
they
see this vaccine happening they're
terrified they don't understand
abstractly why this helps them and they
associate this with deep fear
that then transitions as they grow older
into an unconscious deep fear of medical
intervention like that especially
needles and then when they're older and
they have rational faculties their
unconscious emotional faculty still is
terrified and then tells the reason
because reason is just our press
secretary it's not actually in charge of
anything it's the emotions press
secretary it basically says
um let me find data to support my
unconscious fear here and then you find
plenty online that says well vaccines
can cause this and maybe they cause that
maybe they cause this and maybe because
that you know what I think I'm not going
to get vaccinated whereas the deep root
underlying that is you were traumatized
you know by the medical intervention
where we strapped you down and gave you
multiple inductions at once so it's very
nuanced and it's an individual thing and
that's why I'm with you that coercion of
this is gonna backfire it's never going
to work you have to educate and do it
from a place of love and let people make
decisions now for school vaccinations
It's tricky because you can harm people
who are unable to be vaccinated because
of their health status and they could
die if you're unvaccinated child gives
them measles or something so maybe you
say well then for public schools you
have to be vaccinated if you're not then
you have to either homeschool or go to a
private school and that I'm on the fence
about you know more
um so that's my thinking on that
yeah that totally makes sense
um for me I actually wasn't afraid of
the needles until I gave them to myself
and then the medication was extremely
nauseating so I'd get nauseous so when I
started getting nauseous after I was
giving myself my needles Then I then I
got an aversion to it before that I
guess I don't know why
um maybe I'm brave but I wasn't I
remember getting vaccinated when I was a
kid and it didn't bug me I was like yeah
in both arms in this one three at once I
don't know when that was but uh it did I
didn't get an aversion until the nausea
started from the medication but I can
see how that could happen to people
nausea is such a
um biopsychosocial thing you know and
what I mean by that everything is
everything's biopsychosocial means we
have a biological component there's a
psychological component and there's the
social component of it and nausea is
particularly in in medicine we have this
term Supra tentorial the tentorium is a
barrier in the brain that separates the
anatomical structures of our cortex
which are the like what we think is our
rational reasoning all that and the
lower structures which are emotion and
that sort of thing and and and and and
more um not even emotional more like our
autonomic structures like breathing and
that stuff that happens in the
background
and we say something super tentorial
when we're trying to say that's
psychologically driven nausea is a great
example when you see the needle and
you've Associated it with vomiting
before like chemotherapy people they
just see the bag and they get so
nauseous yeah it's and it we evolved
that I mean it's important protection
mechanism it's a disgust response and it
keeps us safe from poisons and so on and
but boy it's hard when you're a kid I
mean I I gotta say this like when I
heard your story I was like just
outpouring of compassion because I
couldn't imagine that's why I couldn't
do pediatrics it's the suffering of
children is beyond the pale like
um yeah so that you've come out this
strong
kind of you know intelligent articulate
person who can talk about issues and
knows who you are that's not the
standard outcome right yeah it's a
result of resiliency and finding meaning
and suffering and so on which I'm sure
your dad could speak to better than I
can but you know Kudos it's not easy to
do
thank you thank you I'm tougher now
um and that that needle fear definitely
went away as soon as I stopped giving
myself a medication I was like
um I could poke myself like I did too
just out of curiosity which is [ __ ] up
but like I was like ah it's gone it's
gone as soon as I didn't like
anyway anyway
um
yeah yeah but it wasn't fun it does make
me extremely skeptical about anything
medical because as soon as I did go why
is this happening to me and then
searched around a little bit I was like
oh wow okay I could have changed things
and I would have stopped this that's not
fun like that made me so angry for like
I'm still angry but I was I was angry
enough that I was getting panic attacks
when I went into hospitals which never
like that never happened I was always I
was always okay and then as soon as diet
reversed all my symptoms and all my
symptoms went away and I went off all of
my medications
um I had a phobia of hospitals for about
I had a phobia of hospitals until I had
to bring my dad to hospitals and I had
to force myself to go into the hospital
to go with him and then I was having
panic attacks in those hospitals and
eventually I desensitized myself and now
the panic attacks are gone but but yeah
it's been it's been a wild ride it's
been a very wild ride nothing that you
said is is unusual or I mean it it all
makes sense you know I I one of the
earliest memories I have is of being
tied down by a bunch of nurses so that
they could give me vaccines and check my
blood pressure and the feeling I
remember this my mom was in the room it
was at her hospital because she my both
my parents are doctors yeah so they took
me to their own Hospital tie me down uh
the things squeezing on me I'm screaming
and punching and and nurses are having
to like restrain me because I'm violent
right and um now
so when I first started training as a as
a physician and I would enter a hospital
I would have this like surge of like
weird adrenaline I couldn't figure it
out and anytime anyone checks my blood
pressure that isn't me my blood pressure
is elevated and when I check it it's
it's low and I realize it's this
conditioning you know it it really is
and we forget that children are
conditioned it's how we evolved we we we
incorporate this stuff and it's still we
until we make it conscious until we see
it or desensitize it like you did by
going in the hospital by facing the fear
this is why all this stuff about PTSD I
need to avoid triggers no you need to
face with help don't do it alone it's
hard but you you that's why we don't
have safe we don't make safe spaces we
don't ban words we don't uh coddle
children we we make them face this stuff
with help and love period that's what I
think we ought to be doing with love
yeah I agree which is why the coercion
doesn't work when I um when when I first
started having those like I went it
surprised me right I went to a hospital
I had a panic attack and I was like what
because there wasn't any it was like a
physical there wasn't even a lot of
mental there right I just had this
physical response and I talked to my dad
and my dad said that's a completely
reasonable response given what happened
to you yeah but you need to desensitize
yourself because you're probably gonna
need to end up you know you're probably
going to need a hospital at some point
which was like way sooner for other
people than I wanted it to be but uh
it's definitely interesting that was
very interesting
you're smart uh no I just talk I'm still
super no no you're smart I'm still very
skeptical but but those were excellent
explanations you should be skeptical if
one person can convince you in a
conversation about something then you're
probably not skeptical enough you need
to continue to get in as much data as
you can and then you have to feel into
it too and go okay well my intuition is
one thing often our intuition is wrong
but what is it telling me about me that
is resisting and how how can I then
recognize the bias and still understand
how to make a good decision for me and
the good decision may still be well you
don't want to get vaccinated fine then
maybe that's a good decision for you
especially given your risks and so on
you know
um
are you on any sort of and you don't
have to answer this because it's a
medical question but are you on any
immunosuppressing medications
that would put you at risk for infection
no but I I was until I was 23. I
literally put all of my symptoms into
remission I have no arthritis and this
is actually really exciting I could
never put my hands on the ground with my
wrist flat like so
um I used to get off the ground when I
was a kid like this because of the
arthritis in my wrist yeah I did my
first push-up in my entire life with my
wrists like this
yesterday I could do that for the first
time in my entire life yeah that's
really I almost cried like I really
almost cried it is emotional it's
emotional and and the thing is you know
and again I think about your story and
and the kind of suffering you know when
I saw the interview you did with your
um with your dad the the long one where
you were talking about his
hospitalizations and the path you went
through I mean that was so affecting not
just because of your dad who you know
have admired and his struggle is is is
you've documented it and it was looking
at you and going wow she's been through
hell on all these sides and yet isn't
insane yet
I mean she's close to it on video on
video yeah my husband today sent me a
meme and is this duck and it's just
paddling and they're on a waterfall and
he's like this is you so on video but
thank you but but you have to accept
that listen you have to accept that the
thing is you're you're the type of
patient that many of us doctors are
terrified of because you you've been
through all this so you have all this
collected trauma you have a complex
medical condition that we don't fully
understand but we think we do but we
want to feel like we do so we reduce it
to receptors and pills and so on but
we've not seen the full biopsychosocial
thing because it's complicated and we
don't get paid for that we don't have
the time for that and we're hurting
ourselves be you know because we're
suffering in a system that doesn't value
connection it values throughput and for
that reason you're a challenge to us
that hurts us morally because we want to
help you and we know we can't and so we
don't have the tools or sources and
autonomy do it so it becomes this Mutual
suffering Cascade that then someone like
you will then go I need help so I'm
going to go and find it and then you
happen to find a very restrictive diet
that eliminated most components of the
diet that then allowed you to feel
better and for you that worked
brilliantly and now you have to suffer
with having that same diet all the time
which I imagine you've gotten used to or
yeah not really it's not like you're
like I'm on freaking like two Foods or
three a little bit more now but like you
don't get used to it you still look at
cookies when they put they put freaking
little tiny nice little cookies at the
table everywhere here and it's much
better like no I don't eat that like
it's fine but you know there's a little
bit of me that's like that cookie looked
really good I I did uh keto for eight
months and uh I got to enjoy it and I
got a six pack and I was like this is
dope and then I realized I wasn't able
to eat with my family at all and they
were starting yeah it was social it's
social issue biopsycho
but see I'm sure for in your Social
Circle having you well
is well worth not having the opportunity
to eat a cookie or a birthday cake with
you right so they're these yeah sort of
trade although it's still one thing
though yeah I would wonder about with
yours since you did such a restrictive
it's a meat only diet yeah
yeah but I went down I did like paleo
and then that worked really really well
a very restricted paleo and then I and
then it stopped working
um and then it was meet and greets and
then it was meat and then I've been on
meat for three and a half years and I'm
just I'm getting better now but yeah
would you consider adding things back
slowly to try to see which elements you
could safely add that's the goal I mean
I counsel people kind of on Facebook for
free and it's not medical advice
counseling
um people on this diet and I've seen a
lot of success with reintroducing Foods
so it seems to have a component of gut
healing and then when that happens like
a lot of these people have been on a ton
of medication for a really long time and
then they reduce their diet they go to
all meat and then a lot of these people
especially if they're not as sick as me
um go on to reintroduce things and
don't have symptoms usually they stay
without you know grains and kind of keep
to paleo if they have sicknesses but the
goal is not to be restricted like this
forever right right and you know so yeah
you said you know gut microbiome I think
is a big component of this stuff that we
don't fully understand I think you know
what you eat that's I think that's part
of the reason why people who uh use a
lot of artificial sweeteners there has
been data that that does alter your
microbiome and and maybe introduces
insulin resistance so even though you
you know you're Downing all these diet
drinks doesn't mean you're not affecting
your gut Flora that then makes you
actually resistant to insulin it's
almost like giving you diabetes a
different way so
there's all kinds of stuff we don't
understand and one of the things about
your diet and again I'm not advocating
anyone diet now I've done videos about
this where I say diet is a personal you
have to individually customize it for
you and figure out what works for you
but people treat it as a religion right
you probably in these circles is like no
you must be paleo or keto is the only
way and it's like well no for me or
people are carnivores
and what happened to my carnivore that
you get within the carnivore Community
you get people are supposed to only eat
meat but right so that that's a that's a
big one and I think that there are
historical periods where people probably
ate a lot of meat but that doesn't mean
that
you can't eat blueberries without
getting arthritis it it's it's really
interesting because everybody's
physiology is different some people
respond to a vegan diet so well I get
fat on a vegan diet
um but I do well with Mediterranean say
but I've had to try every diet to try to
figure out what works for me and uh I
used to be very carboverse and now I
find that complex carbs actually will
fill me up in a way that allows me to
eat less overall but it has to be the
right thing like whole wheat bread with
nuts in it so it's very unique and and
the thing is you have to find it for
yourself but diet often evolves into a
kind of a identity and a religion that
can be can be detrimental when it's
looked at that way your diet is
interesting because what it does is it's
whole real food so you're cutting out by
nature of it all the processed stuff
that's what veganism certain veganism
and certain keto has in common it often
cuts out fake food which makes it
although Oreos I believe are vegan so
there's that
there's that yeah the diet I'm on gets a
lot of criticism for being like well if
you just cut out processed foods and
like seed oils and all these things
you'd be fine but I did that for like
two years two and a half years and then
I I was eating like it was good I just
had like apples fruit salad sweet
potatoes fish meat like a bunch of
things and then it stopped working after
after here's a clue I went on a round of
really intense antibiotics and then I
couldn't tolerate the carbs anymore so
I'm like it's got to be microbiome
microbiome related yeah yeah it's we're
such complex systems you know I had a
guy in my show yesterday Federico fagine
he designed the world's first commercial
microprocessor for Intel that basically
now is this and he's an old Italian guy
and he comes on here and he has uh
awakened to this idea that uh humans are
not machines because he's worked on
artificial intelligence for like 30
years and what he determined is were
these complex
Quantum classical systems and that's a
fancy way of saying we exist in the in
the quantum probability world that's
very infinite and crazy where
Consciousness is and then we are also a
symbol that exists in this classical
world where we look like stuff that's
very simple and deterministic and we can
predict how it behaves but because a
human cell is not just a machine it's
this Quantum classical interface that is
driven by Consciousness itself
you can't reduce things to simple
answers right yeah the microbiomes there
those are living creatures living in us
that are cells part holes of them
themselves and we ignore it all we try
to reduce it in medicine because we can
we go well in medical school they taught
us about receptors and Gates and
channels and drugs so
a more integral perspective is a
holistic perspective and saying well no
it's actually all these things that's
why patients like you and I refer to you
as a patient just because I'm now I'm
talking to my audience right so patients
like you
instead of us shutting down and going we
don't understand she must be crazy she's
only eating meat is it the medications
we gave her that made her crazy enough
to only eat meat that's literally how a
lot of healthcare professionals think
right no no you're you're this complex
system that's trying to figure out
what's best for you and you're trying to
teach us something not just about you
but about other patients like you and we
ought to be there open and listening
with compassion and also humility but
it's hard because trials
yeah I would like some carnivore
carnivore trials I'll join that one long
as good yeah well I think that could
that could how will you notice and it
hasn't been done like keto studies are
done why is there no carnivore study yet
you know be interesting is to do it have
the placebo group be all fake meat and
tell them it's real meat like you're
eating like the impossible Burger the
thing is you tell in a second
yeah you tell in a second that wouldn't
be fair that wouldn't be fair uh okay
thank you so much for coming on I would
love to talk more
but it's been an hour that was very
interesting thank you uh where can
people find you online if they don't
follow you already so we're on all the
platforms our biggest is Facebook but if
you just go to
zdogmd.com2gs because one is necessary
but not sufficient to be a gangster uh
you can find everything and uh join our
you know supporter groups subscribe to
our videos we have a podcast version if
you don't like watching my face uh but
it's important to spread the word about
um thinking rationally and clearly and
compassionately
that was fun thanks again thank you
[Music]